her family
like Chris Rock made that joke he goes
men can't go back because sexually and
women can't go backwards in lifestyle so
like as women it's just like yo remember
when you're a teen and you dated the
first guy you dated who had a car and he
could you could pick you up take you out
whatever when that when that ended
you're like yeah I don't [ __ ] with guys
who don't have a car anymore yeah yeah
and I only fight good guys who ever
comments
that proves Maxi's point about 10
sleeping with threes
no I think I was just saying about
lifestyle about what a man can do but
this is why I said to women's
entitlement because when you give them
that lifestyle the next guy they're
expecting that they could have earned
the lifestyle yeah but you gave it to
them no no no no no I'm saying I'm
saying like like even themselves like
could have they could have the job and
earn it themselves like one of the
things Kevin Samuels used to say was
like if like to go down in lifestyle for
the guy that you want but like most
girls don't want to do that because the
thing is I know you're saying that we
could or the girl could earn the
lifestyle but
honestly if it came to you free and you
had to work for it which one would you
take if it was given to you if your
lifestyle was exactly so they wouldn't
want to work for it if they don't have
it can I ask you something Maxie what's
wrong with the guy actually giving a
girl that's not as high level as he is
financial life financially yeah what's
wrong with the guy dating a three and
her thinking we weren't talking about a
three financially we're talking about in
her oh
yeah he's probably just [ __ ] her
that's the difference
it does something to her mentality what
is wrong with her wanting something
better there's nothing wrong
okay okay uh okay this is we're gonna go
back to the cars
we have a used a Honda Civic with a lot
of miles and they they feel like they're
entitled to new BMW prices and they want
new BMW prices but when all the BMW
buyers are like nah that's a Honda Civic
I don't want a Honda Civic I want the
BMW they they they're like no offense
what's wrong with wanting what I want
you can want what you want but can you
get it
and in this club
22 year old and then the Honda Civic is
at the 30 something plus but the the guy
that owned the BMW drove the Honda Civic
for like a week and now
and great addition to my analogy
yeah he was test driving yes
I think they've got more value than they
actually do is this my new buyer and
he's like oh no yeah
are you trying to say what's wrong with
Aiming High is that what you're trying
to say like I just feel like if okay if
for me if you're saying three is a whole
package I think that means she's not
worth that much right well I think what
Pearl is trying to say if threat me if
I'm wrong is you're fishing way out of
your league
simply yes
well it's out of it's out of like okay
so what top 20 20. it's what men value
so like if if men value Purity Youth and
you don't have Purity and youth and you
want a top 20 guy in terms of income
like I just think it'd be hard there's
exceptions but but I'm not feeling
entitled it's just
yeah I think I think what I was gonna
say is I think the mistake a lot of
women can make is they think their
league is the guys who have sex with
them and their league is actually the
guys who will commit to them literally
because men are judged with a caliber
woman they can get whilst women are
judged by the caliber man they can keep
very true if you can't keep them and
then you have no value in that situation
but do you see how that confuses a woman
though not really because if you're if
you're smart and not it's not smart but
if you're just and this is why I always
talk about self-awareness and a lot of
us lack self-awareness if we were truly
self-aware and cognizant of our
behaviors you can understand that okay
here's this guy who I'm attracted to but
based on these behaviors he's not trying
to do anything to keep me yeah we'd
never ever take things at face value
well you don't know women and this is
what I mean by women who actively know
ignore reflex because you know when you
look in hindsight this guy wasn't doing
[ __ ] like he literally slipped in your
DMs said when I'm coming to your yard
and you're like yes
is this from experience
it is confusing it is confusing to the
woman who doesn't understand men and I
think a lot of women don't and a lot of
women don't and I think a big a big
reason of that which is part of the
reason why this show is as big as it is
is because whenever men in recent 10 to
20 years have expressed okay this is
what I like this is what I look for this
is what I commit to a lot of the time is
shamed is misogyny and patriarchal etc
etc so then what happened was men like
all right we're not going to say
anything we'll just show by our actions
but I think what can happen is like you
said like especially for girls having
sex with a guy and she really likes him
she gets clouded yeah so she doesn't see
oh actually no all the men who all the
women who are actually getting
commitment they're moving in this way
and the women who aren't getting
commitment like myself they're doing the
same thing I'm doing and it's hard to
see that I understand that well comes to
the man's fault and that's and that's
the problem because it's yeah it's not
your fault it's the woman will say well
you didn't treat me right when in
reality it was never right in the first
place people treat you how you allow
them to treat you yeah but why must the
man treat wrong like why must you just
because
because he's not he's not okay
this is good okay this is what girls say
when they're shooting out of their
league like like they'll say oh why
isn't he treating me right now he's just
not giving you the attention you want
because you're not on this level but
where he can get any girl he wants it's
easy easier easy
it's like okay okay let's go back to the
cars
that's a free test drive on a car that
has no intention of buying is he going
to go to the salesmen that are you know
selling these really nice cars when they
can kind of see that he's not looking
for anything or is he gonna go to the
Honda Civic dealership he's hungry to
make yourself yeah but because he's a 10
he could probably still get the girl
that's a 10. that's the point though but
why can't he go to the Honda Civic guy
and say oh I want a test drive but Dave
is basically I'm not basically buying
this car because
yeah because then he would he wouldn't
get the test drive yeah
yeah
guys like come to you just like hey look
like you look nice yeah I just want to
have fun with you today
you wouldn't do it he's gonna be like
you got nice cheeks and I want to spread
them tonight but that's all I want oh
cheese what I would say is this a man
tells you what he wants to do his
actions
this
and I hope you'll be in a better
position ah thanks and I think for a
minute it's the opposite I think men
need to listen more look less because
some guys get some guys would tolerate
nonsense because she's so far you know
he's like yeah I don't think that's even
the main focus for men because you have
to remember when you look at it
holistically only 20 to 30 percent of
men are actively having sex
so really for true happiness to be
sought is there's a there's been there's
been this death of average so average
women don't want average men that's true
and those would work all together so if
only 20 to 30 of men are having sex what
does that mean it means that most women
are sleeping with the same men yeah but
if you ask a woman do you want to share
the high value men that you've got they
will say no but then what makes really
different from any every other pretty
girl that there is out there because
once you hit once you become a 10 guy
every woman on the market becomes
available to you so what makes you any
more special than another woman so
please advise her what would you then um
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible